hey this weekend i finished a book by  michael easter called the comfort crisis  it's phenomenal it's an excellent book  but it reminded me we have to create  lives where we regularly and  intentionally do hard things things that  make us uncomfortable it's a thousand  degrees outside right now and i'm  shooting a show in just a few minutes  but i'm going to take a few moments and  go outside and get hot and get  uncomfortable it's good for us you got  to move your body you got to change what  you eat get in an ice bath take a cold  shower have hard conversation tell that  person that you love  that you're not having it anymore that  you need them to hear your needs too  right our bodies are dying literally  dying because we're trying to take the  comfortable easy way out of everything  no more  today start doing regular hard things  every day and you're going to find out  you are way stronger than you ever  thought you were